this is Startalk so Jesse from Vancouver
Canada would like to know this given
that there is an upper limit or upper
speed limit to the universe being the
speed of light and a lower speed it's
not just a good idea it's the law
buckle-up galaxies exactly you never
know okay and there's a lower speed
limit oh by the way the buckling up
you only buckle up because the cart your
cart changes speed right not because it
exists at any one speed at all well it's
the change that's pretty change is what
will kill you yet right that's why you
can be in an airplane going 600 miles an
hour at 39,000 feet and they say you may
now unbuckle your seat right because
nothing's going to happen right if you
maintain your speed that's not a problem
yes if your speed changes and that's
what your seat belt is for and I just
love that they put seat belts on
airplanes as lit enough I get it for the
turbulence but for the crash really
really do you really think that seat
obama crash buckle your seat belt buckle
up okay no I'm not my favorite one is
like you know if you don't bring your
seat back up to four inches you're gonna
die right correct yeah what's the only
one who dies okay so given there's a
lower speed limit which is the absolute
zero temperature could velocity be
considered a dimension like space length
width and depth you have to ask where
you gonna go with that what are you
gonna do with that because for example I
you can have a speed and then I can slow
you down with brakes
did you change dimension I mean what
were you getting with that why what is
the purpose of even having half thinking
about it that way right if you want it
by the way creative thinking is highly a
good thing in this world okay but if you
do so ask yourself is there something
you will now be able to explain that you
couldn't before that's it because
everything we've constructed about
velocity and speed and all of this we it
it's as Einstein said or was it his
protege said space tells matter how to
move and matter tells space how to curve
Wow is deep is that's a great way that's
great it's deep so in that sense it's
not your speed but it's the gravity
that's creating the dimensionality of
the fabric of space you can move within
that so we move within the fabric of
space so the velocity itself is not
there's no cause to think about it that
way that's at two so I applaud the
exercise yeah yeah exactly it's very
creative thinking and your answer jesse
is dark matter yeah just say I will
never answer one question with something
else we don't know anything about right
see that's how I do it but it'll do yeah
people say oh can we explain this thing
in terms of consciousness we don't know
what consciousness is so just back up
right right give it space that's funny
but see you know what that's a that's a
great little cheat though it is a cheat
it's a great chin to complete cheat yeah
people do it all the time that makes I
mean lissa cuz oh I don't know about
this well why don't we think about it in
terms of something else we don't know
about exactly that'll answer is that'll
answer it right that's very funny right
this is Startalk
you
yeah